[Música]
buenas noches
mi nombre es leonardo milán y
y artísticamente leonardo miranda y en
esta ocasión voy a dejarle un fragmento
de una canción un poquito de una canción
que es una samba porque porque con esta
samba hay un antes y un después de mi
vida cambió totalmente mi vida esto
[Música]
silván los saludos al viento mi voz
viene trayendo tu nombre canción
canción que no cantaré nunca más
porque es canción de los dos
canción que nos cantaré nunca más
porque canción de los dos
solo en el vino te suelo encontrar
cansado de andar y de anna
tiemblo al pensar cuando te ame
como hago para él
habla al país
cuando te ame cómo hago para olvidar
[Música]
muchas gracias muy amables
es un fragmento de una canción porque
con esta canción yo llegué a la casa de
el patriarca del folclore nacional
latinoamericano
don horacio guarany y ahora sí guaraní
para aquellos que no conocen fue el
referente máximo de la década de oro
abrir las puertas a todos
del folclore nacional
donde nació un antes y un después con
esta canción que es del de su propia
autoría y yo llegué a
amarla
yo nací en un barrio común de esquel
década de nuestra patagonia argentina
si me permiten me voy a parar para no
estar sentado ahí está mejor muchas
gracias
y
desde aquí
un día
siempre cantando desde niños hijos de
padre músico como decía el colega madre
ama de casa hermanos cantores tíos
cantores y abuelos cantores bisabuela
cantora
crecí entrenándome con el canto
y un día tuve un sueño de que conocía
horas igual a la adolescencia con con mi
niña que tenía meses mi hija
y me levanto un día y le digo a mi
esposa soñé que me atendía o las iguala
ni te imaginas lo que fue contárselo no
solamente a ella sino a todo el mundo
que me conocía los amigos
bueno qué lindo soñar que te conocí
guaraní que te atiende en su casa
cuántos sueños tienen cada ser humano
pero eso no solamente fue ese día sino
no soñaba todos los días sino que me
acostaba pensando en eso tan fuerte que
esa es la primer foto que tuve con él en
luján en plumas verdes entonces me daba
tanta manija me acostaba pensando tanto
en ese sueño que dije que casi todas las
noches soñaba lo mismo eso habrá sido a
mitad de año este sueño
y rompí los confort de la vida
el confort de la vida es tener un
trabajo una obra social tener tu casa
tener todo bueno me dieron todo en esa
época cuando nació mi hija para tenerlo
y rompió el confort porque yo dije me
voy a ir a buscar este sueño
agarre antes de fin de año dije me voy
agarré una guitarra un bolso y como
siempre digo con hambre de cantar pero
más hambre del otro también
no me digan cómo hice para llegar a unos
aires como hice para menos como hice
para llegar al lugar no conocía no
conocía nada solo sabía que tenía ganas
de cantar y confiaba en que guaraní me
iba a tender
seguía luján
al llegar a luján preguntándole a los
vecinos dónde vivirán y si alguien sabía
dónde vivían horacio guarany y
supuestamente en plumas verdes por su
canción yo que era seguidor referente
del canto popular del criollismo de lo
patriótico
de los caballos de los campos de
jineteada actualmente todavía sigo
haciendo montas especiales jineteadas a
lo largo de todo el país
golpeando golpeando así como me vende
bombas agua hasta que doy con el
paradero
le tocó timbre me atiende la esposa
quién es hoy el muchacho un muchacho de
la patagonia hice más de 2.000
kilómetros con mi guitarra yo quisiera
que me escuchen o no está el señor eso
fue un día al otro día
lo mismo me quede es perder el colectivo
no tenía dinero no tenía nada me quedé
y siempre encontraba un rinconcito donde
quedarme algunos me ofrecían siempre
buena gente en la calle restaurantes
cantaba para comer
1 medio donde dormir al otro día
caminando 40 50 cuadras soy el chico de
la patagonia que vino para ver a guaraní
no está el señor se fue de gira me decía
su esposa griselda que después conocí no
al tercer día y así una semana
tras mi sueño
el último día paso por la basílica de
luján y había un padre afuera le pedido
una oración sale caminando como todos
los otros días
le toque la campana toque el timbre si
quien es el chico de la patagonia más de
2.000 kilos y ya se me cebolla a ver si
está cuando me dijo así yo dije estás
escuché el junk letter
que venía y yo dije sale la señora no se
abrió el portón y tenía la imagen de
horas igualaría en frente mío parecía
dios
claro imagínate los así no me dijo ni
hola con su personalidad me dijo qué
querés yo quería ver si usted me escucha
imaginé que ahí se me terminaron todas
las palabras el que más palabras tienen
se me terminaron todas yo quería que me
escuche pero como te voy a escuchar
y me vio tan insistido
mi hijo pasa
pase a la casa
se imaginan lo que fue para mí venir de
acá de esquel 2000 kilómetros para
llegar y después de una semana estar
intentando que me abra la puerta ya el
sueño estaba cumplido estaba en la casa
llamamos amigos levantaba el tubo porque
me dijo sentate saca la guitarra le
cante esta samba me dices es mía y si
ahora si es suya
empezó a llamar a sus amigos empezó a
llamar a otro empezó a llamar a los
artistas a todo el mundo
y llamó a uno de sus a su asistente más
de 25 años personal a su asistente
personal de gira
y el asistente me llevo a su casa me
quedé en su casa
ya cantaba en buenos aires mandé a
buscar a mi esposa mi bebé
me quedé en buenos aires no volví más
no hable más
por eso digo yo que los sueños tienen
como un efecto dominó
yo al dominio que va cayendo uno cae el
otro que el otro bueno en los sueños son
así porque después no solamente me quedé
y empecé a cantar en buenos aires andaba
por acá cantado por allá cantada por acá
después ya vino quería que grabe a
grabar cuando yo pensaba tener una
grabación a grabar en buenos aires grabé
el primer disco a nivel nacional
después un día es elevan leonardo tiene
que estar en canal 7 canal 7 en la
televisión radio radio nacional radio
acá otro programa américa 2
otro sueño humano lo podía creer
me lleva a cantar a luján cuando me
escucha cantar completo un show digamos
es este chico le tenemos que poner un
nombre no puede andar así por la vida
sino más mañana se llama miranda y mira
cómo se viste yo ya me bautizó quién iba
a pensar que yo cuando había soñado
que quería conocerlo que además me iba a
bautizar como leonardo miranda que me
iba a cambiar el apellido al que no le
gustó mucho mi papá pero después era
guaraní
ya me había bautizado después empecé a
andar en los escenarios un escenario
otro escenario a cantar junto con los
artistas
a conocer artistas que yo lo veía por la
televisión
compartir escenario con artistas
chaqueño palavecino
rubén patagonia
abel pintó atendiéndome en un camarín
pasa a leonardo
ya otro sueño más
y así el efecto dominó de los sueños se
van cumpliendo y cumpliendo con las
ganas
y todo lo que tenemos dentro se cumple
no muchas veces los confort de la vida
como digo hacia la felicidad
no no sé si lo tengo
no sé si lo tengo lo del confort de la
vida
una casa
todo lo que el mundo tiene que tener
pero si sé que soy feliz
atrás de mi sueño
atrás de eso
de cantar de grabar
de estar de seguir tras los sueños
seguir con el sueño
de quedarme
y un sueño lleva a otro como digo yo el
efecto el famoso efecto dominó por eso
hoy te digo a vos que estás escuchando
la voz que
que no vaya en tu sueño atrás tuyo que
tu sueño no te persiga vos vos perseguir
tus sueños pues perseguirlo existe bola
salir
porque lo vas a encontrar como lo
encontré ellos
por eso
te digo de esta manera
no te desnudes muchacho para comprarte
un traje nuevo
el blanco está en la pureza y el celeste
está en el cielo
los colores de mi patria empecé a
sentirlo adentro unos cantando otros
bailando otros con mal ambos nuevos y un
paisano de a caballo
esa es la patria que quiero
volver pensando hacia atrás no es
retroceder en el tiempo es darle lugar
al folclore al gaucho esa es la patria
que quiero muchísimas gracias
[Aplausos]